and it's impressive how sticking to the
basics matters so much a high level have
we seen a lot of from skilled determine
a lot of a a VP a a Fe and now with a
lot of his momentum starter for him all
time in long yeah we you know sometimes
a a and PB might be your only punishment
certain situation so you guys don't want
to give up that punish right you don't
want to leave damage on the table or you
don't want to leave frame advantage on
the table sometimes right so they kind
of take it but with that you Toro is
going to move on the current doesn't
have losers bracket
obviously but that's the first match of
our we're the first player in our
winners finals is going to be you toto
now we're gonna find the second player
in that winners finals because it is
going to be be be G's blue got from the
US California West Coast versus op ones
skill out of France by the way Volkl top
three alright anyway we're just getting
everything established machine both
players you can see skill on camera
right now just so Freddie getting the
button checks hammered in yeah so um in
terms of character matchup rear I do not
think we're gonna see any sort of change
at all both of these players have been
true to their guns the entirety of this
game's lifespan it's more than likely
gonna be mitsurugi versus as well this
matchup is I mean you know as was a
little different now than he was before
right and hunt suit is kind of the same
except for at the fact that the 12th
frame C is not like three anymore you
have to like get that the you have took
the charge for it to be 12 for you I
swear it so so so having said that right
you still know what I kind of like about
this matchup for skill come is that
actually as dumb as it sounds
Mitsu really could just do a lot of
damage by just doing like he'll sweep
over and over like a a he'll sweep a a
how sweet he didn't actually get away
with that type of style as well and I
mean you see a lot of that mileage or a
lot of that move give um give him my
Lynch skill mileage in in previous
tournaments right he'll sleep it's tough
it's no matter what I don't care who you
are it's hard to be active so so it
seems to me that if
blue guy doesn't do something to make
skill uncomfortable it's it's almost
like distance like a free match but sky
I hate to say that rob who guys not that
blue God is not amazing right but if
blue God cannot throw skill off his game
literally skill is is gonna just pound
them into the ground just like I totally
understand what you mean but one thing I
do you want to note about without
specifically is that if there is someone
who understands the numbers and just how
hitbox interactions work and things like
that it is blue God he is one of the
biggest students of the game I have seen
in a long time
just get that Munchak underway I'm not a
hundred percent sure exactly this is a
very important match up so of course
they want to make sure that they're in
their post comfortable environment
before they start this this matchup
could dictate if you're guaranteed top
three years right so if you guarantee
how many points you get here in the Soul
Calibur World Tour because remember this
is an edge master event first place is
300 points that's right 300 for first
and you know people don't usually
remember who gets third place so that
definitely makes a big difference skill
look at the taken for France blue god
for the USA this has kind of been one of
the biggest matchups as well Julie for
for Soul Calibur 6 is history right is
America versus France it kind of started
the mix-up last year where America would
did fairly well right
III don't think it's a that's hard to
say but you know as time went on this
skill and and the other French members
started to start it to catch up you know
started to do very very well but here we
go first match on Greece stage the
French players think think very highly
of themselves with good reason I
definitely think it's warranted
I'm gonna get the launch right there
console low as well as was trying to
fight his way back he finally got into
sorts and that means Adso Francine oh he
tried yeah I mean it was close and I
think he had the right idea you know
that was a change of back during season
one it used to be a lot easier to take
people off those half-height walls yeah
exactly small walls were a lot worth
it's not gonna hit the wall okay I was
worried for a second
that also was cheeps and I hit the ones
often as they use - just fling you like
nasty - where's like whenever you hit it
was on the wall is gonna be a combo
skill take it the first round right here
okay that oh you tried to replenish
right there he's in all mighty stands
now because of it nice step nope nah
nothing big again skill is just I don't
understand who's doing so much damage
with just the basic stuff it's always
been like that so kind of a world
Invitational if you watch those matches
you'll notice that skill pretty much won
off of just 5a and stuff like that I
believe that's the buddies what is blue
God play me a symphony
my love you my actually so charge hello
I spray it's gonna be a weird prospectus
whole charge here I think because he
could use that meter for the next round
possibly trying to catch it with the
lethal hit on that
no guys thump what another throw oh not
it is a guess it is a 50/50 you're right
and I mean the trip damage from taking
the throws not gonna kill you but Sally
I mean it still hurts it still gives you
a point will mention as well they get
lots of bus after when you crate to
throw a group on ice couple new god huge
lead in this round whoa no with punish
yeah I think that's like kind of the
differences between the two players is
mukada hits like big damage combos right
whereas skill is kind of playing
straight up just like I'll take what I
can get here and a net their mouth sweep
whoa just a little bit too far out of
range okay it's gonna force this old
sorry dad you recognize what situation
he was in and also if he loses this
round he's gonna get that far back whoa
nice tough but he couldn't get anything
for it
go blocks again and this time you guys
so charge yeah he wants to get that
pressure going be right there excellent
he puts up the stop sign right you know
when you're in sole charge as well and
you're in almighty basically right so he
can press whatever fast button he needs
whatever button he needs to put as a
stop sign
Phoebe the sign from skill oh we will
cancel a recognition of the string right
there God believe it as well let's go
break dancing on them now forcing the
sole charge right now skill kind of with
his back to the wall honestly oh okay I
guess it maybe he was doing it a [ __ ] I
don't know why he was jumping Oh Michel
stuff she raised right here from blue
God the first came him right there so I
cannot stress enough by the way this is
a run back from grand finals of the Soul
Calibur world Invitational where we're
skill kind of ran away with the hardcore
I'm sure thought about that and you went
and looked at a lot of things that he
was doing wrong in this particular
matchup and it is clearly showing right
now with that half-life lead at round
start your missed comp with time at the
legs right off giving him space I think
he's a little bit too worried about the
reverse way we mentioned it earlier he
is such a student of the game he doesn't
understand what mid summer his options
are rare and he is going to the correct
answers this is really impressive you
know it's hard to consistently be this
aggressive against going don't he's
trying to step he's trying to crouch
under what you're doing like that right
there and yet new god is making it
happen so far yeah it just it was so
difficult for him right now I don't know
if I've seen if he's so difficult for
him at any point at any time skill can
take off just like this
that ledge is looking mighty dangerous
for poo god yeah and he's thinking about
that that was a very smart crowd trying
to get the to a he's kind of living on
the prayer with that amount of help I
don't know if he's gonna be able to do a
whole lot with this it's so hard to come
back for this position I bet soon he's
gonna play defense of me off whoa that
was so smart use five bees in court and
cancel the animation wait for the 2k
afterwards early so charged with new god
yeah he wants an urn whoa I'm surprised
that didn't Sun punish use the new soul
the new attack in sole charge
I always attacks when they're not
absolutely nice man can I go for the
soul charge right here you need to get
him off him he understands regardless
you will get this bar back if you I if
you lose you put about a good point by
the way this so attacks you can do in so
yeah it's soul attack right muscle
buster coming out oh so charge combo the
low-end stance right now my back man
that range is so good under since be
when he's at all by these stairs oh my
goodness keep watching us and across 3b
there's not gonna go cowboy here I think
going for that full crouch oh oh my turn
nice lunch right there okay Paco
he's trying to work up to that ledge bit
by bit book Luke I'm an accountant
punished and now he actually has the
Ashura blade buff as well let me please
gonna get an option new options right
here he gets access to better faster
frame better and new moves oh nice a
crown suite oh my god Wow okay that was
poured through and now he's in all my
T's dance oh my god
incredible